how long is this because my Uber's here
[Music]
anybody here like fishing I like fishing
I like fish I like the idea of fishing
but I've never been oh we gotta go never
been fishing dude let's do a JK fishing
trip I would love it deep sea you know
what I think I think we should do a
regular fish and chip and then DC
deepsea number one when you go to DC
they [ __ ] take you out there and then
they got all this technology and [ __ ]
and they take you to the fish where you
just put down your line they they lined
it up for you they give you the bait for
you they clean your fish for you you
just drop it and you start getting tired
because you're just catching fish yeah
bro I caught like 30 mackerel one day
did you really how big were that they
were like we kept throwing away but we
got we got like eight fish we got like
eat them on the boat yeah dude no we
took them home we made some fish tacos
it was phenomenal is it true that I
heard the cool part about fishing is the
serenity that like you you're forced to
be in while you're like waiting maybe
like the boring ass people who told you
that that's the part that I like but
it's like golf right it's more about
hanging out like that dude fishing is
fun we gotta go is it about the fish
wait you want to come fishing with us
although deep sea fishing does sound fun
because it seems like there's a lot of
action there's a lot of action a lot
action can we do fishing where we catch
fish and not Turtles on accident
oh God you caught a Turtle Beach a bunch
of times on accident really it's the
same one a bunch of times
to pull a turtle in I'm not gonna say
where but it happened recently where
were you [ __ ] fishing Turtle Cove no
but close to where I live
and I was like oh no oh [ __ ] I would
hate to catch a turtle that would [ __ ]
me and [ __ ] you up were you fishing in
the the lake in your guys's Community I
can't I'm not gonna say anything it's
like these baby turtles you [ __ ]
caught a turtle a bunch of times
I caught Leonardo Donatello and Raphael
I see him at a mall I see them all with
their Pawns
when you're a kid by the way and you're
watching the Ninja Turtles and you're
seeing them get wailed on by the Foot
Clan you don't hear those noises oh no
you heard little turtle screams oh geez
man all right you need to go anyway we
need to go fishing with him where do you
wanna where's beginner fishing I want to
go fishing dude deep sea deep sea is fun
though because even if you're a beginner
you're gonna get the immediate
gratification because the worst thing to
do is be a beginner Fisher go to a real
fishing spot not catch something for
five hours and be like why the [ __ ] did
I do that that's why we go oh I lied I
did go fishing once the first time ever
did I ever tell you guys when I went
spearfishing no your first time fishing
is spear fishing you're so barked so uh
a lot of my buddies in high school were
spear Fishers because they're like
whacking they're on the swim team a
bunch of losers I was on the swim team
dude and we were just talking each other
up and for some reason we're like we
should go spear fishing and we're like
okay let's do it right now so my buddy
we go to the Chinese supermarket because
those fish are already swimming around
in a fish tank we literally buy a
[ __ ] trash bag full of swimming this
is not the right spear fishing we took
them and dumped it into his pool
we donned all the spirits so they're
already dying of chlorine we've done all
over the topic all of all of the spear
fishing gear and we just went underneath
I'd rather [ __ ] fish for Turtles and
we just started blasting and then the
mom comes home and there's [ __ ] fish
guts all over the pool and there's chips
in the plaster because when you miss it
hits the [ __ ] Plaster of the pool
shake that did you guys accidentally hit
the little pool filter buddy that's like
floating
somebody actually hit that bucket so I
don't think my first experience was the
right one I don't think my butt oh
you've been fishing before I don't think
they did me a good thing and the fish
were hella weakened by the chlorine bro
you didn't even [ __ ] hunt yeah you
already holding your breath yeah dude
these fish are dying what a thing to do
that's a very Bart thing to do in high
school that wasn't my idea it's very bar
and it's very gel at the same time Joe
wasn't there Joe wasn't there yeah but
still didn't have to be there I think we
put him there JK Adventure we go [ __ ]
I'll take you guys fishing I got fishing
stuff I love fishing where do you go you
go to the beach okay the closest spot to
me is actually a terrible spot to fish
which is Lake Balboa terrible spots why
because the fish there's nasties it's
first of all it's a man-made lake so
they put in like little ass [ __ ]
catfish and a little ass bass and stuff
like that at least they don't put in
turtles that sounds terrible that
happened at the man-made lake I'm
familiar with it's it's fun to fish off
the pier even though it feels kind of
ghetto a little bit let's get the gummy
fish fishing on the Pierce fine dude
let's go let's go I love it deep sea
fishing we're not doing the [ __ ] okay
do you see what happens if we catch a
real big turtle
but anyways there's a fishing there was
a fishing a tournament
now I I want you to take this seriously
because
it might not be serious to us because
not as relatable but I wanted I wanted
to relate it to us okay it's relatable
all right so there's a fishing
tournament that was hit by a huge
scandal
after an entrant allegedly
not really allegedly because you got
caught
stuffed his catch with weights in order
to win oh yeah he's trying to win oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah and he did win he
did oh that was huge because this dude
this specific guy has been doing it a
long time and he's won Millions oh [ __ ]
was it Millions yeah that was a big scam
dude that's what they were saying that
this dude over the years that he's been
doing it from like different contests
and whatever deals he's made he's like
created a reputation for himself explain
to somebody who doesn't fish like this I
don't fish so when you that's a turtle
right
it makes screams and screams basically
Simple Story you go to a fishing
competition usually in the competition
the person who catches the biggest catch
wins the grand prize so even if it's not
like physically big it's gonna be based
off of weight so if you take a [ __ ] a
fish and you put literally an actual
weight in it and you know when you're
using a fishing like a bob weight or
anything like that or like a drop catch
weight it's literally grams and or
nearly a pound right that could be the
difference between a winner and this
fool is stuffing them down his catches
and then weighing his catches winning
competitions over and over so he would
catch it and then stuff it stuck in his
mouth and it's been fishing for like
tuna those things could be like 300
pounds he sounds smart so if you're like
stuffing weights in there you could
literally put [ __ ] like 45 seconds so
they have that amount of time in between
judging to stuff their fish yeah I would
assume it's the moment when you're
reeling it in and then you grab it
right there right and then how do you
make that look well the judges are just
like this one's big boned you know and
like it's just like the women I have sex
with it like pops out of weight they
always make jokes so here's uh they're
chummy they cut it up you know this this
is that the uh tight knit Community this
is that the recent tournament where he
finally we got caught and when he gets
caught it's uh you'll see there's two
people in the video one is him we'll see
his back and the other person is the
director of that tournament competition
who ends up catching him after he's
already won and received prize money at
the event this is like just after he
gets called out for cheating so then the
director ends up going up to him after
the fact calling him out for it this
guy's so [ __ ] shocked that he like
doesn't even deny he just shuts down he
just shuts down silently just [ __ ]
getting [ __ ] reprimanded for a [ __ ]
as the Director starts [ __ ] flaying
his fish and weights fall out weights
how long is this because my Uber's here
oh yeah
[Music]
see sounds like a boys club
holy [ __ ] call the cops
so it's this guy who got caught
not even moving I want you to leave
those are the fish right there oh it's a
small fish so watch them watch them oh
yeah yeah it's gonna cut it open
out weights whoa that's a big boy
[Music]
foreign
it just says initially his name is Chase
Chase Kaminsky and Jake Runyan they took
on the gold following the way in uh this
is just behind the scenes uh Discovery
this was live streamed
um and then suddenly there's a bunch of
confusion that happens during the live
stream on the side of the stage and then
the camera ends up kind of panning over
to there and that's when all the yelling
and shouting I feel like somebody would
have to see him do that in order to be
confronted and then try and prove it
this is why you just don't tell your
wife about your personal [ __ ] stupid
because they're just there to destroy
you like like and I'm not just I'm not
being like extra
but they don't want you to win I mean
from a a man who's
relationship is on the fritz some of
rocks to the Rocks yeah so I get I get
where you're coming from he was even
stuffing it with with more fish
yeah yeah more fish literally taking
like a [ __ ] like bait or fillets of
other fish yeah
yeah just putting it in the fish to add
I don't see what's wrong with this fan
of redundancy that's okay how did they
find out like that's crazy
how do you just go like this guy's
foolish I wonder I wonder if there's a
guy who like who's in second place who
has this giant fish looks at the first
place with his like mediocre fish and
it's like I don't know
yeah I can't or he's like I do like the
big bone [ __ ] but man I don't know
there are there were a lot of comments
in like like if you go to like the
fishing IGS where these communities are
in a lot of people are like we always
[ __ ] knew that guy was cheating like
how do you win every single time for so
long apparently that's why they're like
dude he bought a boat he was like made
all this money doing this [ __ ] so they
that's why they're so pissed because I
bet there's not a consistent winner you
know like because I feel like it's a
it's a it's a game of chance isn't it a
little bit because you're playing with
another variable that you're not in
control of yeah exactly you know what I
mean so it's like for him to win
consistently that's probably when
everybody like if you're a real
fisherman you probably know that like
how are you getting these fish every
single he was getting away with it too
if he's putting ball bearings in this
[ __ ] fish yeah like you're getting
away with some [ __ ] that's like an
evolved plan like it probably was
smaller and less detectable and by now
he's like [ __ ] these guys putting
billiard ball size yeah holy the density
probably felt uh have you uh have you
encountered people that are like uh
cheating in your guys's respective
Industries uh and Instagram Fitness yeah
how's that one instagram fake weights
like so out of competition it's really
hard because you have like three refs on
you and literally the day before you
check in for a power lifting me like
they check your materials okay it's
cotton underwear you're not wearing some
stretchy like material that has crazy
rebound or whatever so like that stuff
is uh it's it's pretty hard to cheat
but lifters like if they're trying to
get Hella views like that's their way of
getting hella views is lifting big
weights so I've seen people like try to
pass off some sort of like assisted
material underneath a big hoodie
or to like add like another 30 or 40 50
pounds oh no way wow stuff like that
where they'll like get a lot of views
and maybe they repeat the process they
might be able to get the sponsor that
they want or whatever I've seen it in
like Fitness IG yeah it's amazing
they don't run into that moment where
they actually get tested and suddenly
can't deliver well it's just it's just
IG Fitness it's not like an actual
they're not going to real events I guess
more power to you if you know how to
work the system right [ __ ] there's no
rules on that right yeah you don't
you've seen Dance judges that don't give
a [ __ ] and will just vote for whoever
their friends are right 100 yeah that's
it
[Laughter]
I know a bunch of dudes that do that
[ __ ] so they say their names
Anthony my song
[Music]
[Music]